-Welcome back to the show.
I always love having you on.
-Thank you for having me on.
-Well, thank you
for being nice to us
when we were Zooming the show
and we really needed guests.
So thank you so much.
I appreciate it.
-It's my pleasure.
It's back to business now.
-How are the kids doing?
-They're good.
It's a lot of Halloween fever
in my house.
-6 and --
-Yes, they're 6 and 5.
-Yeah. And so Halloween fever.
What are they being?
-Yes. It's hectic.
So, Rocco, my 6-year-old --
he decides he's in charge,
so I'm Wonder Woman.
-Ah, there you go. Good.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just got my costume
in the mail.
It's pretty nasty.
-You got to fix it.
-Yeah, I got to do
a little customizing.
And Bobby's
going to be The Hulk.
-Oh, of course.
-Yep.
And Rocco's going to be Thor.
And my little one, Rafa --
he's going to be Jafar.
-Wow! Interesting.
Interesting curveball.
He's like,
"No, I want to be Jafar."
-Yeah, he was practicing
his voice last night.
You know, "The rest of
the treasure is mine!"
Like that.
-"Just give him the treat,
and he'll get off your lawn.
Sorry. We'll get it right
for Halloween."
-You know, the little hat on.
-Yeah, it's so cute.
In Australia,
did you have Halloween?
Was it a big thing?
-No, we didn't.
It was like, you know,
we had, like, a crappy pair of,
like, cardboard ears
and drew on, you know, whiskers.
And, like, you'd knock on doors
and get, like,
you know, a carrot and an apple.
Something. They're like,
"What are you doing here?"
-Wow! Yeah.
Wonder why it didn't take off.
-I know, I know.
It wasn't really a thing.
But here, it's like magic.
I'm so into it.
-Oh, it's the greatest thing.
-It's wonderful.
-Well, last time Bobby was here,
he was telling me
about this movie --
he's playing
a Neil Diamond impersonator --
that you're producing?
-Yes, I produce with my company,
Dollhouse Pictures.
It's called "Seriously Red."
And he kindly did
a little cameo --
Well, he has a big part in it,
and I do
a little cameo, as well, yes.
-Yeah, you play
an Elvis impersonator.
-Yes, it's set in the world of
impersonators, obviously.
-Here's you as --
The debut of you as Elvis.
-Yes.
-Yeah, not bad.
I like this.
Did you --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Did you have
an Elvis impersonation?
-I mean, yeah.
It's like, you know, "Thank you
very much," that kind of thing.
But it's not --
You know, "impersonator"
is the key,
but it was a lot of fun.
We shot during COVID in 2020.
And it's --
-What made you think, "Elvis --
that's the one I'm going to do"?
-Well, my girlfriend, Krew --
she wrote the story.
And it's about a young woman
called Raylene,
who's a bit of a misfit,
and her aspiration in life
is to be a
Dolly Parton impersonator.
So it's an ode to Dolly Parton.
It's a love letter to her,
about her music,
and the icon she is.
-And the characters you meet
and the people you meet.
-Yes, yes.
-Are you so excited?
You are a global ambassador
of Australia.
-I know.
-Rose, it doesn't get bigger.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It doesn't get bigger.
"Come and Say G'day."
Rose Byrne, you've done it all.
-Come and say g'day, mate.
Yeah, it's so surreal.
These campaigns have
a great legacy in Australia.
And, you know,
Paul Hogan famously did one
and Chris Hemsworth
and Kylie Minogue.
So I feel very honored to
be part of this kind of story.
And, yeah, it's incredible.
-Are your parents excited?
-They are excited.
I took my dad -- We shot some of
the campaign in Uluru,
which is in
the middle of Australia.
It's an incredible spot.
And I took my dad,
which was really cute.
My parents
are here tonight backstage.
What's up, Mom and Dad?
-I did get a chance
to say hi to them.
-I know.
-They're so cute.
-My brother is here.
-And your brother, too, yeah.
-He thinks I should retire
now I got this campaign.
-Yeah, of course.
He's like, "Oh, really?
What else could
happen to you, Rose?
Oh, my gosh.
The favorite child."
Yeah.
-No, no, no.
-What's your brother's name?
-George.
-Do they -- Everyone
has nicknames in Australia.
-Yes, we do. We do, yeah.
-Georgie?
-Jerry.
-They call him Jerry?
-Yeah, Jerry. Jerry Dog.
-Jerry Dog, yeah.
What would I be called?
-Well, 'cause you're --
You're James obviously, right?
-Yeah, James, yeah.
-So Jim, so Jimbo.
-I've been called Jimbo.
-Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy Jack.
-I like Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy Jack.
Yeah, that's pretty fun.
Well, the big part of the
campaign -- Here you are here.
You are Ruby.
-Yes. Ruby the Roo.
-You are the toy souvenir
of, yeah, a kangaroo.
This is --
And also the director.
-Yes. He's an old friend of
mine, Michael Gracey,
who directed
"The Greatest Showman."
-Yeah, a little film.
-Little film.
-No big deal.
-So, he directed this,
and it's really sweet.
It's seen through
the eyes of Ruby the Roo,
who I voice this character.
She's gift-shop kangaroo
and she's desperate
to break out of the gift shop
and explore the country.
And she's very innocent
and curious and warm
and fun and lovely,
like Australians are, you know.
-Yeah, they are. You're right.
I want to show everyone
a clip here.
You can check out
the full film at australia.com,
but here's a little clip.
Here's Rose Byrne as Ruby
in "G'day."
Take a look.
-There are like thousands of
things you can see
on the reef --
coral, turtles,
boobies, tiny sea --
-Wait a second.
Did you say "coral"?
-G'day. Welcome aboard.
-Whoo-hoo! Boat trip!
Come on, Louie!
-This is humiliating.
And also strangely comforting.
-Hold on. Ooh! Ooh!
Excuse me.
-Let's go, folks.
-What are you doing?
We're not going to make it!
-Yes, we are!
-Ohhhh!
-Whoo-hoo!
-I mean, come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"G'day." Rose Byrne.
We are playing a fun game with
Rose after the break.
Stay here for more
from your short film
from Tourism Australia.
Stick around.
-What a beautiful day
to go snorkeling.
You guys been out to the
Great Barrier Reef before?
-[ Gasps ]
The Great Barrier Reef!
Huh?
-Here we are!
-[ Gasps ]
G'day.
-Uh, where am I?
-Australia.
And you look like
you need a vacation.
-Show us what you got.
-Let's go.
-Welcome to
the Sydney Opera House.
-It's remarkable.
-Yep. it's amazing.
Whoa!
-I love it! What is it?
-A wombat.
-♪ Australia ♪
-Oh!
-[ Laughs ]
-I see kangaroos.
-Me too.
-Come on!
-G'day, mate.
-Hear that? We're mates.
Aaaah!
-Whoo-hoo!
-Aaaaah!
-Jump!
-♪ I come from
a land down under ♪
-G'day. My name is Freddie.
-Wow! There's nothing
like Australia.
-Special, huh?
-It would make a great movie.
-[ Gasps ]
-So, what are you waiting for?
Come and say g'day.
-♪ Whoa, oh, oh ♪
♪ We come from
a land down under ♪